um what is something because I you know
I feel like you kind of had like a rough
Shake in terms of like the music
industry kind of ending up over with
Kanye
um I feel like you were kind of
mishandled you know respectfully
um do you feel like you like what did
you learn from your previous label
situation that you're you can apply to
your career now
um
really just uh
well that's a great question bro I love
that question but um
what I'm moving with now just really
just like just a team you know what I
mean just if I'm saying like word you
know I mean respectfully yeah I mean to
not know offensive other team I was with
former team I was with but just the team
love if I'm saying it's more of a like
compassion is more of it like we we talk
together mornings they checking in you
from saying it's bigger than just music
with them you know I mean it's a family
you know what I mean and that's what I
got right now you know I mean with my
new situation with Riverton Andrew Scott
Alyssa if I'm saying like we moving and
it's just that love it's that yo we
going we going to the top we getting
bigger and bigger what do you got um in
the chamber right now music-wise you got
a project coming or you dropping
obviously you're dropping singles and
stuff what's next or um honestly man we
got a new album we working on right now
you know what I'm saying cool you know I
mean I'm gonna start I'm gonna start off
with what's coming out tonight bro you
think I'm saying bigger and bigger you
know what I'm saying that word make sure
y'all tune in it's it's it's wavy you
follow me triumphing you throw me The
Vibes some of my favorite instruments in
the world yeah we going up we going up
and then I got got before I'm saying the
vibe of the problem for me word you know
I mean the album is coming up
new color for me what's the name of the
album new color new color yeah I like
that word what's that mean oh man is
this I'm the way I see things nowadays
big bro like you know what I'm saying
like
the through a new lens you feel me you
know what I mean so it's it's seeing and
reaching for new color you know what I'm
saying so observing in love with color
you know I mean the God what God
creating is you know I mean the Bible
just the A1 you know what I'm saying
word Star Wars Vibes y'all know Star
Wars